Son of Krypton versus bat of Gotham what
have you done
as if December didn't already have
enough gifts we've now got another full
trailer for Batman vs Superman and while
some people think this is the gift that
gave away a little too much it's still a
gift nonetheless and I'm still excited
about it it's full of hints and teases
and Easter eggs and other words that
mean the same thing but if you do think
I end up missing something we might have
already covered it in our last breakdown
of the first Batman vs Superman trailer
feel free to check that one out too
let's dive right into this one who's
that you must be new
that is Bruce Wayne we start out with a
different perspective on a party we've
already seen glimpses of before and it
sets the tone for this trailer right off
the bat no pun intended I just mean that
this trailer unlike the last one
actually isn't as focused on the action
and fighting between our two main
characters but rather their ideological
differences I'll come back to that
insight so this car that Bruce is
driving is an Aston Martin db4 3 and
it's a fun reference because that's what
James Bond drives in the novel version
of Goldfinger and in the Ian Fleming
novels that's the only car that bond
ever loads up with gadgets and as we
know from Bruce's other car
he really likes cards with gadgets if
you notice the moment when Clark gets
his first glimpse of his main antagonist
for the movie that peaceful violin music
is interrupted by a discordant piano
chord not the most subtle thing but
still pretty cool let's move on this
away
Clark Kent David can it what's your
position on the bathroom I am gone we
then enter the party which seems like it
could be some sort of charity auction
with this bike on display in fact maybe
that's the same one that Lex is riding
in the other trailer also this artwork
could be for sale too but taking an
extra look at that artwork if you're in
Los Angeles there's a small chance that
it actually might look familiar to you
that's because it's painted by an
la-based artist Cleon Peterson who
paints these really epic but dark scenes
of violence and torture and this one
looks like it could be an extension of
his piece called
a balance of terror and like most art
there are a couple of different ways to
look at it and I think that's why it's
being featured in this particular scene
but I actually want to keep moving
through the trailer so how about I just
revisit that as we go cool all right
let's go civil liberties being trampled
on your city
people living a pair thinks he's above
the law after Clarke asks Bruce about
the bat vigilante in Gotham he points
out that that guy's trampling on civil
liberties every day people of the city
are having to live in fear and at this
vigilante thinks he's above the law so
about that painting again it depicts
simple everyday people attacked by dark
shadowy figures who actually wear black
underwear and even as they maim and
torture these people the casual demeanor
of the dark figures implies there's no
one around policing them they're an
unchecked force sounds a lot like
Clarke's perspective on the bat
vigilante right the trailer matches
Clark's words with this change of
criminal who's been branded with a bat
symbol now I'll admit that actually
sounds a bit meaner than Batman usually
is portrayed so either Batman being set
up to look worse than it is or Clark
might be right and we might be seeing a
version of Batman who after being out
there for so long has actually got him
pretty ruthless also fun to note that
the brand made sure to leave that
diamond-shaped space for the Superman
logo
thanks for the consistency now as for
the newspaper itself we'll come back to
it Daily Planet
crystallizing those who think they're
above the laws hypocritical watch
yourself
considering every time your euros
there's a cat out of tree you're in huff
beast editorial
about an alien have it burn the whole
place down so we still see this shot of
the Gotham Free Press newspaper it
becomes an example of how the Gotham
press covers the Batman story showing
images of him putting criminals away by
any means necessary to contrast with
Bruce's criticism of Metropolis his
newspaper and Clark Kent himself the
Daily Planet criticized you know she's
like they're above the laws hypocrite by
pointing out that all the Daily Planet
writes about their hero is huff pieces
where he saves cats out of trees or
Russian cosmonauts from explosions or
people from floods but that's not just
meant to contrast the newspapers or even
Gotham and metropolis but actually the
differences in what the job of a hero is
according to these two men Superman sees
the role of a hero as one who comes to
the aid of the helpless saves people
from disaster while Batman actually sees
the hero's job as putting an end to the
threats in the first place seeking out
the criminals the darkness and
eliminating threats before they can
strike at all it's no wonder that he
describes Superman as an alien that
could burn the whole place down he's
technically right about that being
possible and that's what he thinks his
job is to identify those people who are
threats and take them out and like I
said before you can look at art a lot of
different ways so revisiting that same
painting from before you might see
something else because when the painter
himself was asked about what was being
depicted in his art he talks about power
he mentions the idea that absolute power
corrupts absolutely meaning anyone with
pure unstoppable power will be
completely corrupted by it his art shows
the absolute power individuals can't
help but see the normal everyday
unpowered people as weaklings that are
there for them to torment and rule over
not only does that sound like what
Bruce's fears of Superman are but it
actually sounds a lot like what Lex says
in a moment about power too you know the
old
Lyonne America senator that power can be
innocent so surprising that Bruce and
Lex might actually be on the same side
for a large part of the movie and
talking about Superman's unbridled power
that's an epic Superman statue and it
kind of reminds me of Atlas who was not
exactly a God but a Titan who were kind
of like the parents of the Olympian God
Alice holds the weight of the earth on
his shoulders and since he just defended
the Earth from an alien attack some
would say Superman does the same but it
is safe to say that Bruce is not alone
and hating on this supposed God since
the other trailer showed us that this
statue eventually gets to face because
it represents worshipping of a false god
it's a pretty complicated situation
right oh hey in that shot you can see
scooter McNary in a wheelchair though we
still don't technically know what role
he's playing but this statue seems to be
part of a larger memorial with all those
candles around it so maybe he's someone
who was injured in the Zod attack from
Man of Steel the way he looks up at the
statue makes me think he's a fan of
Supes but we still don't fully know this
girl doesn't share your opinions Dwayne
maybe it's the gotham city in me we have
a bad history with freaks dressed like
clowns
okay this stuff is pretty
straightforward but incredibly awesome
Bruce confirms that Batman's got a dark
history with the Joker and the timing of
that shot of the deface Robin costume
really makes it seem like the Joker
didn't pack kill Robin there's actually
a lot more to say about the Joker in
this movie and Suicide Squad everything
but luckily we did a whole other video
on that and how the Joker might not be
the real Joker if you check that out
after this video but it's also kind of
funny that in a very simple way Bruce is
just making fun of Superman's costume
like I guess it is a little more
clownish than dressing up as a bat but
still you are just as likely to see all
three of those looks at a birthday party
oh and speaking of Joker like clowns
let's keep going boys Oh Bruce Wayne
meets Clark Kent I love it I love
bringing people together how are we rich
hi hello Lex it is a pledge oh wow that
is a good grip you should not pick a
fight with this person so we get a big
dose of Lex here and he's definitely a
bit of a clown and some say the
inclusion of this comedic feel and this
trailer was an attempt for DC to show
that they aren't as dark as everyone's
making it out to be and they can be just
as quippy and funny as Marvel and what's
funny about that is that the new civil
war trailer is anything but quit being
fun now they're the ones that seem all
Atari but whatever who cares there's no
reason we can't have both it's all great
and anyway I actually think that Lex is
playing up his silliness here just like
Bruce Wayne in the Dark Knight trilogy
when the billionaire distracts people
with is outward eccentricities no one
dives deeper to see what they're really
up to and who they really are on the
inside ah dresses up like a bat clearly
has issues it's kind of fun to note that
at this moment here there's three of
DC's biggest characters all in one room
all hiding behind their version of a
secret identity when you combine that
with the other trailer you'll remember I
think Wonder Woman is also here in her
secret identity too and that's just
another reason why I think this scene is
just gonna be awesome though it does
make me wonder even though they're all
in some form of disguise doesn't it feel
like some of them might know the truth
like the way Bruce talks about Superman
and he is the world's greatest detective
so that wouldn't be too surprising if he
knew his identity but also the way Lex
talks about the two of them
Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I love
bringing people together it suggests
that sure this is his event but also
that he might be the one who
orchestrated their entire feud in the
first place like maybe after a Congress
didn't punish Superman enough he's
created a situation where he uses
Batman's distrust to attempt to kill
Superman that kind of evil brilliance is
totally typical for Lex because some
consider him to be one of the smartest
people on the planet though there's a
lot of debate about whether or not he's
smarter than that man but this shot is
still a nice reminder that as big a
threat as those two are physically Lex
is just as serious a threat making up
for his physical size with the size of
his vast intellect okay let's pick up
the pace a little bit you're the oldest
lie in America senator the power can be
innocent
some [ __ ] brought the war true us a lot
of these shots we've seen before and the
other trailer so I'll only point out a
few things this long walk scene had an
extended cut release right before this
trailer but the big speculation with
anything in this orange e tint is that
it might just be a dream sequence
since the toys refer to this costume as
nightmare Batman also that Luther quote
I mentioned before about power not being
innocent is timed with this footage so
it would make sense that this version of
a corrupt power-hungry Superman is
Batman's worst nightmare of course this
is all just a guess
also in that Senate panel here and we
get another glimpse at scooter McNary
and pairing this with him at the
memorial makes me think he's gonna maybe
testify on Superman's behalf which would
line up with the guests that he might be
playing Jimmy Olsen Superman's best pal
just a version with no legs this cool
shot of the new Batcave reveals that it
might be underground somewhere that's
connected to water be it sewers or
something like a secret swimming pools
of the Paris catacombs and you can see
what looks like the Batmobile and the
bat-computer and the Robin costume from
before so it looks like the graffiti
isn't there yet which is interesting
because it fits from the Joker does that
mean he's running around Gotham at the
same time as this movies taking place
but also maybe the graffiti is already
there and we can't see it it's a pretty
blurry shot the rest of this section is
just Bruce's perspective on the Zod
attack for Man of Steel so let's move on
your conference
it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
Son of Krypton versus bat here's where
the real action of the trailer starts
and we see a really good look at
Batman's mechanized battle armor and
notice the way you can see his normal
suit arm there that means that this
thing isn't like the Hulkbuster type
armor that covers them entirely but more
like an exoskeleton that he wears kind
of like Ripley's power loader from
aliens that strap is probably for the
gun that we'll see him with a little
later we'll get back to her and these
shots being fired at Superman they seem
to be coming from all directions and I
wouldn't be surprised if it means that
clever old Bruce Wayne has designed a
specific location to be a trap for
Superman ah since the 90s comics they've
used Superman's charged-up eyes to
indicate that he's like beyond pissed
which is a really helpful way to know
that someone should not be messed with
but let's keep going you're psychotic
it's a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds
Seidenberg good means to be a man
you be good already note that Lex has a
hand injury here and I have a couple of
guesses about it but I'm not confident
enough to totally stop for them so let
me know why you think he has a hand
injury and then we see this really cool
shot of Batman
smashing through glass but the way he
uses his cape creates this silhouette of
a bat symbol and it's really reminiscent
of the look of the bat-signal nice after
some cool shots of the Batmobile there's
Batman slamming the hell out of Superman
into a wall and unless my eyes are
deceiving me I think we see Superman
spit out blood so this moment right here
indicates that Batman might have brought
Kryptonite to the party and if that's
the case it's anybody's game the next
shot has that orange hue so again it
might be a dream sequence which would
make sense why they're all these creepy
inside creatures flying about however if
we are lucky those are not just random
insect creatures but instead parademons
who are loyal soldiers to Darkseid now
Darkseid is way too big a villain to
just throw in there casually but if
these are paired demons then they might
be foreshadowing Darkseid as a villain
from the upcoming Justice League movie
that'll be epic and finally we get to
this badass Superman quote here go but
one it
dead already a lot of people were
wondering if this movie would dance
around the fact that at the end of the
day Superman could pretty easily just
crush Batman and with its SuperSpeed
Batman wouldn't even have noticed it
happen
this line not only admits that yeah if
Superman wanted he could easily kill
Batman but it also reveals that this is
less a battle of abilities and more a
battle of will and in the graphic novel
hush Batman defines this battle pretty
clearly if Clark wanted to he could use
his super speed and squish me into the
cement but I know how he thinks
even more than the Kryptonite he's got
one big weakness deep down quarks
essentially a good person and deep down
I'm not that's such a badass moment and
you should totally read hush but it also
explains why these two are able to fight
at all it's about just how far they're
willing to go to win let's keep going
man we'll kill God
what have you done and that right there
is the moment a lot of people think this
trailer should have ended but it still
showed us a lot more so uh some
interesting stuff to point out here
before I dive into all that other stuff
main Lex in a lab coat might seem
strange for these days but the Lex as a
rich successful businessman that's
relatively recent like that's only how
he's been portrayed since maybe the 80s
but before that he was always more of a
mad scientist using his crazy inventions
to try to take on Superman then we do
that old shot of Zod bod with Mercy
graves guiding it through Lex Cora and
even though we now know that our
previous guess was right and Luthor uses
Zod to create doomsday which by the way
thank you to all the commenters that
have been congratulating us over on that
other video bars you guys are very nice
thank you but it is worth pointing out
that they seem to be using a lot more of
the origin story for bizarro here you
see back in the pre-crisis days Zod was
cloned into a bunch of bizarro soldiers
and in the post-crisis day Lex Luthor
made a messed up clone of Superman that
resulted in bizarro also the creation of
bizarro has many times been compared to
that of Frankenstein's monster and
seeing the dead body here the lightning
and electricity it's all seems to result
in a monster that seems to still hold
true here too and I think that's because
a lot of people always doubted we would
ever really see the true form of bizarro
in a movie because based on the way he
acts and talks it it'd be really hard to
make him come off as anything other than
a mentally handicapped version of
Superman what is it
very ugly dress you are wearing we like
it a lot while you scream me bizarro me
friend
Cesaro is not the most politically
correct of villains so it seems like
they're merging things here and giving
us that backstory but leading to the
creation of doomsday now doomsday
himself has an origin that I think is
pretty awesome and I covered it in that
other doomsday video so if you want to
know more about that check out that
video some quick other things to note
that line of Luthor's man won't kill God
the devil will do it so the devil's
doomsday and the god he's referring to a
Superman but what about the man that
won't kill God this could refer to
mankind like congress's and punishing
Superman or something but also it could
refer to the fact that Batman was
supposed to kill Superman reaffirming
the possibility that it was Luthor who
planned their fight all along and that
didn't work so now he's making doomsday
also why is Superman just standing there
behind him so calmly combine that with a
shot of Superman kneeling to Lex in the
other trailer and it makes you wonder
what Lex has on him or if Superman is
like under some sort of mind control
I don't know and the building near the
Superman statue it's being lit up by
electricity and I could be wrong but
that looks to me like it's water
cascading down the side now wait earlier
in that newspaper there was a mention of
funding cuts to the water board made
them put testing on whole could that be
related to this weird experiment here
also there's testing being done on water
that's one way to get an Aquaman pissed
at you but also seeing that picture
again maybe that's not connected to this
building but instead it could be where
the new Batcave is located
I don't know whatever it is I think
there's something there moving on what
have you done
okay and here we are the last section of
the trailer and her big doomsday reveal
and some people think we're seeing
doomsday because they wanted to show a
big difference between this movie and
civil war other people think it could be
because most of the toys of the
characters have already leaked and they
didn't want us to get our first glimpse
of doomsday through toys I don't know
but here he is though he doesn't look
exactly like the doomsday we know in
fact he kind of looks like a combo of
abomination from Incredible Hulk and the
cave troll from Fellowship of the Ring
the recent Ninja Turtles and dare I say
a little like Michael Shannon himself he
has his father's eyes but one reason he
could look a little different is because
one doomsday power that makes him such a
big threat is that he adapts to damage
so he's already got a bunch of these
bony protrusions throughout the fight he
could end up growing a bunch more bone
as he adapts and then he'll look just as
adorable as were used oh and speaking of
doomsday powers he doesn't normally have
heat vision or whatever the hell this
whole face thing is but that kind of
makes sense if he's based on Zod also I
think this reaffirms the likelihood that
a shot of Batman dodging a huge blast
earlier is probably from doomsday and
not Superman like the editing implies
and speaking of tricky editing there's
something going on here because it's
unlikely that Batman went from being
seated and strapped in to standing with
a gun in his hands in like three seconds
but he is Batman so maybe oh and
speaking of that gun a lot of people are
like no way Batman isn't allowed to use
guns that's not entirely true he has
used guns before he doesn't prefer them
but he was just fighting Superman
so an exception makes sense and this gun
in particular looks to be the one they
showed off in that glass case a while
back making it actually a freaking
sticky grenade launcher you got a hand
in a Batman if he's gonna use a gun it's
gonna be a grenade launcher I'm actually
excited to see how it works I'm also his
voice in this moment I thought Church is
here it sounds very different from the
so each voice is probably tied to what
he's wearing and that means he's using
technology to alter his voice rather
than gargling shards of glass like
Christian Bale says that actually could
be a cool idea that they borrowed from
arrow Oliver Queen uses a similar trick
to alter his voice refills and finally
she's barely in this trailer but she
almost steals the entire show with her
epic entrance Wonder Woman so very cool
her badass shield can apparently
withstand a full-on heat blast and I'd
love to see how it compares to caps
vibranium shield but that's something
happen ah but aside from that you can
see there's ancient like Greek
inscriptions on it I have absolutely no
idea what they mean so let me know if
you think you know okay and one last
thing I want to mention about that
painting the artist has also said sure
he's depicting images of the powerful
killing and torturing but he said to
remember that the victims of yesterday
become the antagonize errs of tomorrow
kind of like how the victim of
Superman's power has now returned to
antagonize him today
I told you there's a lot going on with
that painting so let's discuss in the
comments some of these themes and our
guesses about the movie if you've got
questions for me you can always hit me
up at fimo and get updates about our
videos and our website at new rock stars
if you happen to be in Los Angeles you
can actually check out some street art
by that artist over on Santa Monica and
Orange Grove see pretty cool right fun
fact my first department in LA was right
over there so if you want to stalk me
feel free alright I've been full of
Molina I'll see you next time bye
yeah lots to learn
we go to college